police say the man accused of attacking
Senator Rand Paul could be charged with
a felony because of the Senators
condition the Kentucky lawmakers
neighbor Renee Boucher is currently
charged with fourth degree assault the
59 year old is accused of tackling the
senator from behind while he was outside
his home on Friday Dean Reynolds is at
the courthouse in Bowling Green Kentucky
Dean good morning good morning well the
Friday fight between two neighbors both
of them physicians and one a u.s.
senator set off an immediate round of
newsroom speculation as to what the
motive could possibly event well what
we've learned so far is that the whole
tussle may well have been about
landscaping this is an open and active
investigation
Kentucky State Police Master trooper
Jeremy Hodges said Senator Paul's
longtime neighbor Renee Boucher was
initially charged with misdemeanor
assault before Paul was medically
evaluated Paul's office later said he
suffered five broken ribs from the
attack if it has found that there was a
serious physical injury that occurred
then the original assault charge which
was a misdemeanor can be bumped up to
the felonious charge of assault a second
degree the arrest warrant for Boucher
said Paul suffered small cuts to the
nose and mouth area and had trouble
breathing
neighbors reportedly said the two men
have a long-running dispute over a yard
waste Boucher admitted going on to
paul's property and tackling him while
paul was reportedly mowing his lawn you
don't usually have one physician
assaulting another physician I'd say
that's a fair statement Matt Baker
Boucher's attorney said his client is
remorseful and the attack was not
politically motivated that is absurd
politics has nothing to do with this
zero Paul's injuries could postpone his
return to Washington making it tough for
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
who is working to round up enough votes
to pass tax reform any time we have a
senator on our side he's not there it's
potentially a challenge now Boucher's
attorney said he spent the night in jail
before bonding out at $7,500 on set
Renae Boucher says he will plead not
guilty on Thursday at his next court
appearance here in Bowling Green Nora
all right questions still remaining Dean
thank you so much